Okay,
we are live.
Hello.
I managed to get through um
pretty much all the client stuff I had
to do.
Not bad.
So, we should be pretty much on target
timewise.
Um, yeah, we should be pretty much on
target timewise.
The only thing I really wanted to do
before we start Monday is
I wanted to compare
a maze perf. Maybe
I wanted to compare a maze perf. Maybe what we'll do is we'll check out
what we'll do is we'll check out
Oro
Let's train four and then let's train 5.
And we're probably going to merge I'm
going to merge the five bow branch back
into four
because we don't have anything that's
like five specific yet and then we'll be
nicely set up.
Hey, Arch.
7 minutes. Okay, not bad.
Not bad.
Then I may or may not also have some
time to look at some other PRs and
things today. We will see.
I'm a bit tired. I need to get my um I
need to get my schedule like properly
disciplined.
We're starting the whole
10k per day and cut thing.
Let me think about this. What else we
were going to do? So, the goal is we
just have to see if there's a large gap
or not here.
I kind of have to train this a few
times, don't I?
Yeah.
Well, that's okay. We have time. It
won't take that long. I think it's worth
if we have to spend an hour on this.
We'll spend an hour on this. Not super
efficient, but that's kind of fine
today.
Um,
I saw you looked at PR.
Oh, was that yours?
Uh, if that was yours, then it's decent.
I just didn't know if that was I was
making sure it wasn't some random
person's just like some random crap.
Like,
uh, I'm actually curious how well does
this thing work? Like, what do you
actually have to change in the
environments to make this work? Cuz I
don't want to have to add like a video
save thing to every environment.
Is there a way that we can very easily
just like know change something in the
veckend file or something
to support headless for everything and
like saving videos or what?
Cuz that's the main reason for Ray
headless, right? I mean Ray 6 is the
headless.
I also wonder how fast that back end is.
So, we're going to train this in 40 with
this seed. We're going to train this
with a new seed. Going to make sure that
this isn't like super seed dependent or
whatever. I remember seeing that on 5.
And we'll go back to 50 and see if
there's a gap.
Should be doable.
Yeah, that's kind of what I'd want to
do. arches. Make sure that that's like
all good.
That would be nice to have.
Hello. Welcome.
And Vol's here as well.
Hello.
I have a um
I got to go in I think like two and a
halfish hours for I got a talk to give
at Stanford.
Um I make sure everything is set up for
that.
But what I figured I would do today is
first thing is I want to do some quick
evals on the maze environment because I
changed the code. I refactored a lot of
stuff for 50 testing and I'd like to
basically have a clean slate with a
known good environment when I start my
50 dev work.
And I want that merged into four as
well.
Changed your hairstyle. It's called
getting a haircut.
When can we see the latest M's on the
website? So, I actually tried to upload
yours yesterday.
This computer is annoying because it has
Windows and I haven't been able to get
the website to preview locally so I can
make sure I'm not breaking anything when
I upload MS. I basically just have to
figure that out or do it on my laptop
and um like upload
Yeah, just upload all the new MS at
once.
I mean once I have that you can also
just PR your contributor information to
the uh the website
talk session at Stanford.
Yeah, I have a few labs. Um, a few labs
I'll be doing talks for this summer
from that video from yesterday.
Yeah. Okay. Vo,
did you fix your broken code?
Windows is trash. Yeah, I know, but it's
what I have on this machine. And this
machine is old enough that I'm not going
to bother reinstalling it.
though I probably should because it
prevents me from playing League of
Legends.
Okay. 98
point whatever perf, right?
at 98.5 PF. Now, as annoying as it is,
we do have to run this again with
another seed. And I'm specifically going
to use the map seed different cuz this
is what I did with the other one.
Recorded posted.
Um,
no arch, but I'm considering doing a
recording of the same talk at some
point. I'm considering it.
It's just like a highle overview though.
It's mostly like it's not really going
to be useful for people who are already
familiar with puffer.
It's mostly for labs that are like, "Oh
yeah, there's this puffer lip thing.
What's this? What's it have in it?" Or
like, "Ah, yeah, we saw puffer in 20.
What's new?
We have a 5090.
Uh, yeah, but that's not on my local
machine. I'm sshed into um into one of
our boxes.
Local is a 3080. It's actually kind of
funny. I don't know if I can show it. I
yeah, I probably can't show it on the
with the where the camera is, but it's
just like this um small form factor
box that I built. Um it's pretty simple.
Yeah, Arch, it's just the slides I
shared. Now, if you look at that link
again, I've added some stuff to them,
but nothing crazy.
What are you doing today?
Uh, I'd like to get the maze changes
from like the 50 branch has a bunch of
maze changes. I'd like to get these
merged in. So, I just want to run some
validation to make sure that 50 maze
learns as well as 40 maze.
maybe view one of the policies on it.
And uh if that works well, then we
should be fine.
grand. Jesus Christ. Yeah, I'm not
paying that.
They were 25 before.
45. That's not a good deal anymore at
that point.
Yeah, that's not remotely a good deal.
They they can say that they're
upcharging because of the pricing, but
no, they've way increased their margins.
They didn't go up by 5K per GPU.
I didn't bother trying to work with AMD
cards.
I have enough stuff to do without also
troubleshooting different hardware.
running them in parallel effect PF
tiny box. It's the RAM.
It doesn't have a ton of RAM.
No, you can't [ __ ] say it's the RAM
because you can still buy desktops with
the 5090s for what, like 6,7K?
Like max spec.
So multiply that by four.
If they priced it at like 30k or
something, then sure. But no. 25.
Uh-uh.
192 gigs.
Okay. But like go do the math on a
desktop kit. Right here. You can
literally do this right now. Whoops.
Let's not do that.
Watch this. So, I can do this
with a 5090. Let's see how much this
goes out to.
5090.
Uh, a real company 9950X. This thing is
good.
Uh, these stock fans,
I'd want Noctuas on it, but other than
that,
yeah, the RAM prices are some bonkers
[ __ ] I will admit.
Has it actually gone up this much?
I didn't think it was that bad.
Okay, that's everything luckily. Jesus
8k.
I thought it would be seven.
All right, maybe 35 is justified then. I
don't know. But not 45 still.
They're charging yeah 128 gigs
versus 96 1,200 bucks. It's mostly the
RAM.
Yeah, it actually look it goes down
below 6K without the RAM. RAM used to be
cheap.
Let me go just let me just go close that
tab.
[ __ ] hell, man. I always like
remember to close all the like the
whatever tabs before stream and today I
just didn't.
When will norm price uh RAM prices
become normal? Ask Gman.
Hello, Hassan. What's Puffer doing this
stream?
Well, let's see. 98.6 98.5. This is very
consistent.
So, what we're we are doing this stream
is we're going to try to merge the maze
changes in, which is the end we're going
to use for testing Puffer 5.
And we'll see if there's a gap. I think
there is a small gap. We will see
I mean, they have to get they have to
get the chips either way
over midnight.
The one thing I'm a little bit sketched
out on is
we used to have like a forward action.
It used to just be like forward. I guess
there's also the OBS encoding is a
little different.
Uh the obs encoding is a little
different as well, isn't it?
unsigned char. Yes, char.
All right. Well, we'll see how this
goes.
It's much cheaper in Asia.
The labor is right.
Train slow. Well, train slow is not
really puffer 4 to be fair. Train slow
is just pietorch.
Like it's puffer 4 with d- slowly is
very similar to puffer 3. In fact, if
you swap the encoder, like if you use
the LSTM version, it's basically the
same as puffer 4.
I mean, puffer 3. All the stuff from
Puffer 4 is in the new CUDA back end.
the hardware. How the hell is the
hardware cheaper in Hong Kong?
I mean, maybe pre-builts are, but the
component cost is still MSRP, isn't it?
I thought actually stuff gets marked up
in China, doesn't it?
At least the expensive bits.
If this ends up matching, then we're
happy.
If this matches, we just insta merge
and then it will have only taken us 20
some odd minutes to have figured this
out. And that's solid.
Yeah, it depends what stuff you order,
dude.
I wouldn't be surprised that pre-builts
are cheaper, but that would be because
the labor to assemble them is cheaper
was what it probably takes.
How fast do you think that the uh the
people doing the pre-builts
professionally do it?
probably still takes them a couple
hours, no to uh put together each
machine and test it because you have to
like put it together, install it, test
the install, download your software on
it or whatever, flash your software onto
it, run that test.
Okay, this is actually better than
before, not worse. This is good.
Turbo Muan. It can't claim to be faster
than Muan.
I wasn't sure. Is it actually faster for
um
is it faster for our size updates? Cuz
like
it might I think at most it'll be like
5% faster.
Let me find those stats. I actually have
on the presentation I'm giving. I have
the stats.
Oh, it's actually kind of hard to tell,
isn't it?
Um,
yeah. So, the actual muon kernels are
only 1.8% of the time.
Uh, but I guess then the mat moles for
Muan, like a bunch of these mat moles do
come from Muan.
I should probably group it. So the Muan
mat moles go into here as well.
I'm more interested in um, it wasn't
Turbo Muan, was it Aurora?
There was like a there was a slight
change to the algorithm that I think uh,
Volo and Jess were investigating.
Well, I don't know if it is Arch. I'll
believe it when I see sweep results.
Right.
We also have um if anybody wants to
check out Lucas's PR,
Lucas uh submitted a bunch of changes to
Protein.
He says that they make it much better on
his language modeling task. I'd want to
see whether it's better on um
I'd probably say like on mazes versus
our old sweep and uh on let's do 2048
since I'm going to change I'm going to
put this change into maze soon which
makes it a little easier. So let's say
2048. Okay, look at this. 992
986. So we actually got a half%
performance. uh in the new version,
which is not surprising. We have a
slightly cleaner movement system and
such. Oh, actually look at this. That's
a big difference. 121 115
down to 97.
That's quite good. So, this is soda.
This is a new soda maze model. Um, we
can simply merge this.
We can simply merge this.
Let's just let's go do that.
Math is cool, too. Regardless,
I'm going to I got to be honest with
you. I don't like math.
I appreciate math when it does useful
things,
but I do not find math particularly
interesting.
Perhaps because I'm simply too stupid to
understand it. I'll give you that. But
it's also that I just I like when things
are useful.
Was this anybody's PR that I know?
This is not This is not from a firsttime
contributor. I don't know who this is
from.
Cool. So the point of this is now
um
I like collaborating with people who are
smart and give a [ __ ]
It's very, very difficult to find people
with both of those attributes.
There are a lot of smart people that are
just like optimized for pretending to
give a [ __ ]
Did we outline the 50 method?
We can start implementing it on Monday.
Oh, of course it still says four because
that's fine.
Can we evict with prioritize replay
or is it a fix history?
Is prioritize replay a fix history.
I don't know if there's anything widely
used.
What are we doing right now? Louis 10.
Um, right now I am just going through a
sketch of the Puffer 5 algorithm to get
it more concretely in my head and work
out any problems. I want to be able to
hit the ground running on Monday and
just implement stuff.
I'm actually unsure what portions I want
to do manually versus what I want to let
Codeex mess with.
At the very least, I want to make sure I
have the algorithm like completely
precise.
This will be considered very strong
curriculum as well.
This is basically the um
this should essentially be the best
thing you can possibly Eat.
Um, it's when I say it's the best thing
you can possibly do, the key insight in
this update is that there's a thing
that's like usually a really big
assumption that you can make, which is
that you have setable state. And the key
is that we make our own environments
anyways. And we do this professionally
and we've done this across a variety of
areas. So if the way to get good
performance is to have setible state,
we'll just do it for every sim that we
build. It's not hard.
might not be that bad. We will see.
Yeah, this might not be that bad.
You have a grand plan of RL.
Uh, honestly, we're kind of almost
there.
There's not that much stuff left we have
to do. We kind of are already solving
very hard problems virtually out of the
box.
This thing is I doubt worth it. Let's
just let's start with This
This should solve it
if you had a fast version. I would think
I would need to see the reward structure
more precisely
because since it's pixel inputs,
they they used a really janky heristic
in addition. So, you can't really say
that Go Explore solves Montazuma's
revenge because of that heristic,
but I would think that yes, this would
solve it. or like at least what is it?
It would do get the same performance for
rather
as go explore at least. What standard
someone meet when doing end of
development professionally?
You should be able to do like one of our
medium-sized environment projects.
Um
like basically on your own while keeping
the code clean.
That's kind of the standard we have for
people that we bring on for our
professional work. And you also need to
have enough of a grasp of the RL that
like you know ideally you can be asking
me for some stuff but ideally like you
can also be answering some like some
decisions that you have to make you can
do on your own as well.
How is constellation used right now?
Used for all of our sweeps.
Check any environment you want.
You have sweep data.
You know, you can uh decide that you
want to look at
any individual metric. Say gamma.
Actually probably you would want to do
like gamma versus perf.
You can decide actually you know you
want this on logit scale
just for analysis of all the sweeps
viz and is it used for metarl or
something applied
that is viz.
So this is a visualization of the data
from protein right. So the sweep data is
used to find optimal hyperparameters
sometimes including end of parameters
and including network sizes.
And then the viz is used in order to
select in order to do analysis and uh to
select
hyperparameters to m that match
conditions that you may want like model
size or training time or whatnot.
I don't see what you would use this for.
Like what you would want to do with this
with Meta RL.
Oh yeah, we do that type of thing as
well, E10. Like we'll use them for
comparisons. Uh we typically will use
them to see if like an environment has
particularly janky hyperparameters
uh based on sweeps we've done for
comparable ends.
you know, we we just look for patterns,
right? Um
so we look for frontiers that are like
this where you have a trade-off between
compute and score. If there isn't one of
these, typically something is very noisy
in the end. You know, we'll look for
we typically expect some of these
parameters to have like reasonably
consistent patterns. You know, like
gamma, for instance, is supposed to have
a stable region.
Uh where did I do this? Train gamma.
This is drone. Yeah. So, there's this
basically this is the stable region for
drone.
Um you can see some of these have
tighter regions.
Here
we typically will want to see like oh
yeah we'll look at like value function
clip. If this gets pushed down super low
we get suspicious.
We can see here that like pryio sampling
is very screwy with this end in
particular. Um this is one where we
would want to like look at this in more
detail because it's not being either
reduce the boundaries or figure out why
it's this low.
I mean this basically just gives us full
insight on how various pieces of our
algorithm are being used like we've got
clip coefficient on vrace
d and row this one. So this is not
really making use of the important
sampling for this end.
Uh where is it? Max radorm.
This one shows us scaling of model size.
You know up until model size
put this on log scale or lin scale. So
up until 512 you get substantial
scaling.
Suspic suspicious that env is broken.
Yeah either env is broken or sometimes
we find out that algorithm could use
improvements for a specific type of
problem as well. It goes both ways.
that don't compile. Yeah. Arch. Um, any
of the ones that I missed that are like
actually functional environments.
I wrote RL with adaptive parameters and
it was more stable. Couldn't the
algorithm just figure out the params?
What do you mean? You wrote RL with
adaptive parameters
and you can't RL it within a single run
really.
This
Yeah, I do. This was RHF. I didn't No,
there wasn't any like hyperparameter
tuning thing in this, was there?
I don't think that there was anything
like that in that result.
I mean, if you think you have something,
by all means, right? You can very easily
test like take one of our harder ends
like maze or 2048 or whatever, give it
some screwy starting hyperparameters and
see if your thing like adapts
automatically or not.
I'd be very surprised if you had
something that matches a a
hyperparameter sweep, Oh,
It's just not even remotely relevant.
Liberty, unless I miss something in that
paper. Or at least the core of that was
RHF. have.
Yeah, you don't have the advantage yet,
do you?
Give me a page if they have adaptive
hyper prams.
I didn't see that ever in this. It's a
68 page manuscript.
That's not the instruct GPT paper. What
paper is that?
Thank you, Vault.
Oh, it's the previous paper. They site,
page three.
Where do you see
I don't see where you see fine-tuning
hypers? Uh where you see hypers in here.
They literally say they use the default
hyperparameters here.
I don't actually understand how this
works. Let me say
But you don't want to target some
entropy
like you don't have target values for
these things
and this is not the target KL. This is
the KL of the target. Those are two very
different things.
So this is the difference in KL versus
the previous model.
Wait, you don't you need an error metric
for this as well, don't you?
Like if you were to do this on gamma,
this doesn't make any sense, right? So
this would be gamma next equals gamma *
1 +
some hyperparameter
and you don't have an error function.
I this doesn't make any sense to me man.
You might throw away a ton of PO ratios.
Those runs go to crap. We already have
advantage filtering for that though.
Like we literally have a method for
that. That was one of the core things we
did in Puffer 3.
Right.
This doesn't really make sense to me as
written. If you think you have something
like by all means throw it on some
hypers and see if you can get them to
automatically tune.
Let me finish. I got to finish this
algorithm sketch today.
I'm kind of just working through the
details of the algorithm either way at
the moment.
I want a nice clean sketch of this
today.
Hey Jess,
currently doing a sketch of the 50
algorithm. The state setable maze is
already nicely ported.
Can you explain to us this here at the
moment? Um so there the idea of the
algorithm is
uh the core idea of the algorithm is
that some of the environments are going
to have their state set every roll out.
They're going to have their states set
to high advantage states
that are stored in a buffer
and that allows you to generate on
policy data in states where uh
states where there is actual uncertainty
advantage is a much better metric of
this than entropy.
So you basically are going to be getting
high quality data for at least a good
fraction of your environments.
I'm working through the details of how
to do this cleanly.
I mean, I could do um
lum key
color correction.
How is advantage a metric for
uncertainty?
Advantage is literally the difference in
like it's the difference in between what
was expected by your value function and
what happened.
Entropy is not uncertainty.
What did you have? Bet.
Is this something I need to look at?
Okay.
Give me a typo to merge while I'm doing
important [ __ ] Sure. I appreciate the
typo PRs, but I'm doing things.
I mean, I wrote the docs in Vim, so what
do you expect?
Um so Jess can work for pure terminal
rewards ends.
However, this algorithm will not solve
environments where you never get any
reward by random exploration.
That will have to be separate.
It will however potentially let you
solve
um
it's possible that you can solve harder
problems like the maze
with this
where like you sometimes get reward but
it's very rare. You need to sometimes
get reward
Uh, a little bit of both, Jess. We have
a couple ideas.
Yeah. No, using LMS for this is
completely that doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense. The LMS are more than 10,000
times slower than puffer.
You don't go work super hard to make
something fast and now it actually works
because it fast and then you bring it
back into the stone age to use the new
fancy thing. Like it just makes no
bloody sense.
is basically like saying why don't we
just use web 3 for this
again. You have to call the damn LLM on
the data.
to think about that.
wait, why do we have questions about
like L like shoving LM into [ __ ] and
like what model I'm using for a random
algo question on the side while we're
doing actually useful [ __ ] here.
Volo, we probably could use puffer for
fusion calibration.
Oh [ __ ] Is it What time is it? Is it 2
p.m. or 1 p.m.? It's 2, right?
Okay, I've got time still.
The useful stuff here is not that
complicated though. I mean, it's
basically it's me coming up with an
algorithm like, okay, you can set the
state of your environment. What can you
do with that?
It's vaguely both based on a combination
of go explore and prioritized experience
play.
state of RAM. You don't need to capture
the state of RAM. You just stick it into
um if you just store the state of the
env in like one strct without pointers
on it. It's very easy to set the state
of just a strct. You don't have to do
anything fancier than that. You don't
have to like go look at registers or
like copy random blocks of RAM. You just
copy the block of memory corresponding
to a strct.
We don't give a [ __ ] about Atari. We
care about real problems.
We have no obligation to stick to the
benchmark of crusty old researchers.
We can have our own.
One of the great perks of not being in
academia.
Okay, but we're not doing that
everywhere.
And no, it's not just passing a state
from function to function.
If you say passing immutable state from
function to function, you're closer.
Like functional programming and
object-oriented programming are both
really [ __ ] dumb ideas that somehow
like programming gurus managed to sell
like different generations on different
ones of those. It's just dumb.
We care about sweep range. The defaults
are generally pretty good. vault.
You don't need to do that.
You just need to run it on like a box
that can do enough experiments quickly,
dude.
All right, let me actually finish this
cuz this one's important to finish.
I think we may as well figure out how
much of this codeex can do.
I got half an hour.
Here's what we're going to do to start
with.
is what we're going to do to start with.
All right.
They're from prioritized experience
replay. They're hyperparameters.
Are we still reviewing PRs?
Um, Anish, I'm kind of just going to do
uh I'm just going to finish the sketch
of this algorithm today and that's
probably it.
I would think you one shot blackjack.
Yeah.
the models are useful for some stuff,
but people very heavily overly rely on
them.
I'm probably going to have this thing
like review and go through an
implementation plan, edit it, see if it
can do it, and if not, do it myself.
are you eating well in Palto? I'm eating
very little.
Uh this is the goal for the next I've
started already the uh training and diet
part, but the goal is to do about I'm
actually probably overshooting it right
now, but about a,000 calorie per day cut
uh 10 kilometer run per day, quick
lifting session with deadlifts 5 days a
week and a few other compounds
and uh to do puffer five in two weeks.
That's the goal.
I don't Yeah, I don't fast. I don't see
the point.
I don't think that there's much to learn
to be honest, dude.
I don't think like model usage is a
skill. Programming is a skill.
Like software is a skill.
I think honestly the main thing that is
the case with the models is that the
whole
the discussion has gotten way too much
into the public sphere and it's all just
like retarding around to raise money and
sell people [ __ ]
Like it's basically as bad as fitness
industry marketing at this point.
I prefer to just ignore it and build
useful things.
Yeah, I got an hour before uh this
meeting.
So, I'm just going to let this thing do
this and then I will see if this does uh
if we do an initial thing with this or
not. I'll play with it
and we'll start serious work on Monday.
I'm also I'll probably make like a
little uh teaser image for it. We'll
make a minieries out of it. It'll be
like a twoe grind thing.
All right, we'll call it for now. Thank
you folks for tuning in. Um, Star the
Puffer on GitHub to support the project.
It's free.